from a refugee detention camp
to an art studio
i paint with toothbrushes because
for eight years
i was in detention and i didn't have art
supplies
mustafa as amitabha tried to reach
australia by boat almost a decade ago
instead he was sent to an offshore
processing centre on menace island in
papua new guinea until he was
transferred to australia for urgent
medical care
they
took eight years of my life
the best time in my life i could
marry i could
work i could pay tax the government says
that offshore detention breaks the
people smuggling model i think they
drive fear into nation
they wanted to show
that
refugees
are illegal illiterate dangerous
and
we have to take these people away from
society
if they don't want people to
die in ocean why they are
punishing the ones who survive
the answer to crush the people smuggling
business
it's essentially stopped
the people smugglers trafficking people
into australia
very successfully and that explains why
when it was first introduced as a policy
it was highly controversial as it is now
in the uk
um but um
now there's bipartisan support um in
australia for the policy
and traditionally most australians have
supported it too
along with turning back people smuggling
boats
but a doctor who worked at a detention
center on nauru island
told me what he saw in the camps keeps
him up at night
i saw people
suffering from psychosis huge levels in
rates of depression anxiety
uh people went into withdrawal symptom
syndrome where they would um shut off
from the world there was a huge amount
of self-harm suicide attempts people
didn't complete suicide when they were
held offshore it was atrocious
despite the criticism the australian
government says anyone who enters this
country by boat without a visa will
never be allowed to stay here for good
[Music]
even a finalist in one of the nation's
most prestigious art competitions the
archibald prize
and this is me
from manus to
archibald it's um
it's a miracle
forced to renew his visa every six
months this is a precarious existence
surviving one of the toughest refugee
policies in the world
nicole johnston sky news sydney